al je vais sortir mes mes arguments
lourds mesdames messieurs et mon
principal argument lourd il s'appelle
Robert Rochefort il est député européen
vice-président du Mouvement Démocrate et
on n'est pas toujours d'accord avec
Rochefort bonjour Robert Rochefort
bonjour écoutez peut-être que cette
fois-ci on va être d'accord mon cher
hric bah oui alors j'aimerais entendre
vos arguments parce que vous êtes
quelqu'un dont les avis sont toujours
très éclairés réfléchis et aidez-moi
justement à à sortir des arguments
solides parce que moi à part l'usage de
la liberté moi je suis tellement attaché
à ma liberté j'ai jamais été un électeur
exemplaire il m'est arrivé de ne pas
aller voter je n'en tire aucune fierté
hein mais bon c'est un truc c'est un
rendez-vous que j'ai avec moi-même et
donc voilà pour pourquoi m'empêcher de
de d'exercer mon libre arbitre voilà mon
seul argument moi Robert Roch écoutez
moi je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis
contre parce que comme ça a été très
bien a dit au début de l'émission si les
gens ne vont pas voter c'est quand même
parce que nous les politiques on est
englué dans un système depuis un certain
nombre d'années qui ne leur font pas
vraiment des propositions qui marchent
autrement dit je crois quand même que
l'abstention qui est très forte et la
faute des politiques et si on le r rend
le vote obligatoire ça veut dire qu'on
fait que c'est la faute des électeurs or
il faut pas changer les rôles c'est pas
la faute des électeurs si aujourd'hui le
système politique est à bout de souffle
c'est la faute des politiques donc vous
voyez il faut pas inverser les termes
des facteurs alors est-ce que vous savez
Éric Brunet pourquoi on a rendu le vote
obligatoire au début non on l'a rendu
obligatoire parce que c'était il y a
très très longtemps et il y avait l'idée
que les ouvriers risquait de ne pas
avoir de la part de leur patron le temps
disponible pour aller voter parce qu'on
votait on votait pas forcément le
dimanche et on votait dans des moments
où il fallait avoir le la possibilité
d'aller voter autrement dit je z vous
réconcilier avec vous-même c'est-à-dire
que il y a un moment où le vote
obligatoire a été fait pour avoir la
liberté de voter or aujourd'hui
évidemment il y a aucune entreprise qui
interdit le vote ça ne peut pas ça peut
éventuellement être le cas quand il y a
des élections qui sont des élections au
Pr d'omme vous savez o à la sécurité
sociale comme ça existait une certaine
époque mais c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui et puis alors il y a un
autre élément parce qu'il faut se dire
la vérité hein aujourd'hui les gens qui
disent qu'il faut le vote obligatoire
c'est aussi des gens qui y verrai euh la
possibilité d'empêcher que les votes
extrêmes prennent trop d'importance il a
beaucoup de gens qui disent par exemple
quand on dit le Front National est
devenu le premier parti en France on se
dit mais c'est parce que en fait il y a
tous les abstentionnistes et si les
abstentionnistes allaient voter alors le
Front national ne serait plus le premier
parti alors moi je crois que quand il y
a un problème et quand il y a un
problème et mais éventuellement une
maladie par exemple on sait toujours que
c'est c'est pas en cassant le
thermomètre qu'on risque de soigner le
malade et figurez-vous que quand on fait
des des hypothèses de ce qui se
passerait si le vote était obligatoire
et bien il est possible que si le vote
éant était obligatoire on est au
contraire encore plus de gens qui votent
on n sait rien en fait hein mais on peut
très bien avoir plus de gens qui votent
pour des votes extrémistes tout
simplement parce que ce serait un
réflexe d'énervement par rapport au fait
que aujourd'hui on endigue leur liberté
on leur met des chaînes en disant vous
oui tout à fait voilà les raisons pour
lesqu aujourd'hui donc les les gens qui
comme moi ne sont pas j'ai ne sont pas
forcément des gens qui sont allés voter
toute leur vie à toutes les élections
euh ne sont pas des gens qui sont dans
l'illégalité hein il faut le dit un
abstentionniste c'est un quelqu'un qui
mais souvent le le le l'abstention elle
est dévalorisée dans dans les soirées
électorales Robert Rochefort moi je
j'observe que voilà l'absentionniste
c'est le type qui est parti à la pêche
quoi voilà c'estp qui pas sérieux dans
mais il m'est arrivé de dire je me
déplace pas aujourd'hui je me déplacerai
pas voilà et c'est un acte fort alors
bon pour moi dans mon rapport à moi-même
c'est un acte fort mais maintenant non
non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que
il y a eu deux il y a eu deux étapes
pour l'abstenion il y a une première
étape de l'abstention qui était l'étape
de on préfère aller se balader parce que
rappelez-vous d'ailleurs il y a il y a
20 ans ou il y a 30 ans on disait en
fonction de la météo tiens sil fait
soleil il y aura plus d'abstention que
s'il fait pas beau ça c'est avant la
crise très grave de régime que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
comme l'a dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
quelqu'un l'abstenstion est aussi une
prise de position politique c'est vous
savez qu'il y a des pays où dans les
bulletins de vote je crois que c'est
d'ailleurs le cas de la Russie où il y a
une dernière case qui est de dire je ne
suis d'accord avec personne et vous
pouvez causer cacher caocher cette case
alors c'est vrai que maintenant en
France il y a la reconnaissance du vote
blanc ce qui est très très bien et
quelque chose pour lequel ma famille
politique c'est c'est c'est est toujours
mobilisé mais le vote blanc c'est pas la
même chose que l'stou oui c'est pas la
même chose mais quand même on peut dire
un truc Robert Rochefort et je me tourne
vers grégoryi l'abstention c'est pas un
truc comme ça par par exemple une
élection qui va intéresser les gens les
municipales de 2014 grégoryi il y a 36 %
d'abstention bon c'est beaucoup mais on
peut toujours le regretter mais il y a
36 % les européennes dont les gens se
foutent il y a 57 % beaucoup plus
presque le double ça veut dire enfin pas
presque le double mais beaucoup plus ça
veut dire quand même qu'on s'abstient
pas parce qu'on s'en fout il y a des
gens qui il s'abstiennent parce que ils
se disent les européennes a rien à
en revanche les municipales
intéressent davantage et c'est une
information desintérêt quand même pas
obligé d'être passionné par je le sens
je le sens un peu moi je répondre à
Monsieur rochfor si vous me permettez
avec sa politique du 15e siècle je veux
juste lu demander de de quoi vous me
parlez monsieur Rochefort vous avez pas
compris je vous citer tu l'art de la
guerre connais bien ton ennemi si votre
ennemi c'est le FN il faut l'accepter
parce que c'est des gens qui votent pour
eux moi je je prends pas du tout les f
moi mes amis ils viennent de tout tout
bord et tous opinions et et mais par
contre il va falloir l'accepter
monessieur le FN il est là donc il faut
le combattre avec des armes
démocratiques sinon vous savez ce qu'il
faut faire il faut l'interdire
maintenant si vous assumez pas vos actes
vous les politiques et ben il faut se
réveiller maintenant est-ce que je vais
me permettre de continuer sur ce ton
aujourd'hui il il y a de nombreux jeunes
de moins en moins jeune ils se
reconnaissent plus dans les valeurs
fondamentales de notre République enfin
je sais pas vous voulez des Coulibali
partout moi je vais vous expliquer voter
c'est un acte revendicateur de son
attachement de son appartenance et son
amour à la nation et laissez-moi juste
finir et si les gens vont pas voter
cantonal c'est certainement parce que
les les les cantonales ça n'intéresse
personne donc messieurs les politiques
je vous invite à à étudier le comment à
rendre le vote obligatoire et à rendre
les voitures h c'est drôle je peux
répondre Oui bien s allez-y vousz c'est
drôle parce que je suis complètement
d'accord avec toutes les tout tout ce
qui est les les motivations de de de ce
qui vient d'être dit c'estàd il doit
être centriste sans le savoir
Grégor Baou mais c'est il a le problème
de Monsieur Baou moi j'ai voté beou deux
fois c'est qu'il a il a le charisme
d'une chaussette sale il rassemble
personne donc mais monsieur vous êtes
députés européens je vous rappelle que
les françaiss ont dit non à l'Europe
rendez la bagnole monsieur moi j'ai pas
de bagnole mais euh je ne attendez
attendez ce qui est très très clair
c'est que moi je crois effectivement
qu'il faut que le Front national soit
l'Assemblée nationale c'est pour ça que
je suis pour le proportionnel donc c'est
absolument pas ça ma mon argument mon
argument c'est que nous il faut que nous
réussissions à convaincre les gens
d'aller voter il faut pas qu'on les
contraigne à aller voter si on les cont
aller voter alors nous aurons encore
plus de gens contre nous c'est notre
métier de les contraindre et de les
convaincre pardon c'est ça qu'il faut
que nous fassions Robert rochfort et
Grégory d'abord Robert rochfort oui moi
je crois que évidemment il faut que nos
citoyens nos concitoyens a une
conscience politique des enjeux mais
cette conscience politique vous voyez
bien qu'elle doit se faire avant
l'élection c'estàd si on rend le vote
obligatoire pour que des gens aillent
dans des bureaux de vote sans avoir
réfléchi à avance fasse ça comme une
corvée prennent à la limite n'importe
quel bulletin de vote et bien qu'est-ce
qu'on aura à la sortie oui on aura plus
de gens qui auront voter mais est-ce qu'
on aura une démocratie qui sera beaucoup
plus vivace est-ce qu'on aura des
expressions politiques beaucoup plus
significatives non c'est c'est la grande
différence avec les grands électeurs les
grands électeurs oui c'est normal que
leur vote soit obligatoire parce qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins nombreux et ils sont
déjà des élus ils sont déjà dans le jeu
politique ils peuvent pas dire qu'
qu'ils n'en sont pas donc il y a une
très très très grande différence alors
maintenant quand ont dit que les gens de
l'UMP comme les gens du Parti socialiste
lorsquils sont dans l'opposition euh
signent des textes pour rendre le vote
obligatoire et ne le font pas lorsqu'ils
sont dans dans la majorité c'est pas par
hasard c'est parce que vous voyez bien
que et je vais dire ça gentiment à notre
ami grégoryi c'est très facile de faire
comment dire des des mouvements de
démago sur le fait de rendre le le V de
rendre le vote obligatoire le rendre
effectivement obligatoire après c'est
totalement irréaliste dans une société
comme la France si vous rendez le vote
obligatoire si vous n'avez pas de
sanction alors vous allez avoir un peu
moins d'abstention mais pas beaucoup
moins de d'abstention si vous faites des
pénalités c'est si vous faites des
amendes là vous AZ des gens qui vont
aller voter pour ne pas payer l'amende
vous imaginez la motivation je vais
voter parce que je ne veux pas payer la
M c'est encore pire que tout c'est une
dévalorisation encore plus
importante la
préhistoire 15 € c'est rien du tout 15 €
or et c'est 50 € on va dire c'est
beaucoup trop donc c'est de toute façon
impossible à réaliser ch Grégor d'accord
ok vous êtes même pas au 15e siècle vous
êtes au-delà parce qu'il y a que les
politiques qui veulent pas voir la
réalité en face écoutez démocratie c'est
démocratos je vous le rappelle le
pouvoir du peuple vous vous voulez pas
voir la réalité les politiques les gens
ils vont pas voter vous savez pourquoi
mais parce que vous êtes inefficace
incompétent mon aujourd'hui excusez-moi
mon patron il me dit aujourdhui je
suispét je suis eff mais je démissionne
mais pouro vous parlez encore lestiques
vous êtes zé la France la criseors par
que le vote sera obligatoire vous AZ des
bons politiques je vais vous expliquer
si on rend le vote
obligatoireors laissez-moi vous
expliquer monsieur laisse-moi expliquer
que vous voyez pas plus loin bout de
votre nez si demain vous rendez de
m'agresser soyz
sypve d'accord c'est votre nouvel ami je
vais mettre un peu de l'eau dans mon vin
excusez-moi je vous explique les
politiques veent pas voir la réalité en
face la preuve c'est que le vote blanc
encore une fois ils l'ont que
partiellement reconnu parce qu'ils
veulent surtout pas qu'un journaliste
aille leur dire que François il a été
élu avec 12 % des voix je on continue si
demain les gens ils vont aux urnes ils
s'expriment soit dans le rejet
c'est-à-dire le vote blanc soit dans
J'ai voloté nul j'ai mis un bulletin
rayé parce qu'on leur a expliqué et qu'
se reconnaissent pas qu'il ne
comprennent pas la politique alors dans
ce cas ce sera aux politiques de de de
de communiquer plus simplement au peuple
et ou voter pour François ou voter pour
Jean-Marc et ça c'est l'expression
populaire ça c'est moc ça c'est pouvoir
du peuple et le peuple abandonné à pour
vous députés européens bon euh il il est
remonter Grégory merci vous pouvez
rester Robert Rochefort mais vous m'avez
dit que vous aviez des oui je suis
obligé justement de partir parce que je
je suis député européen donc j'ai du
travail excusez-moi bon je vous souhaite
une bonne journée